well it's a Sunday and I'm at Parque
Pilates this is a popular place for
people to get together and play pickup
games next can spread themselves on
being the very best at football
well this Gringo's here to school them
alive and unknown and leave a legend
Laura how are you almost I'm fine how
are you do you have any questions for me
about my abilities yeah
well I played once in summer camp 1974
well relatively you know if you're
thinking about geological history no
pretty recent
have you ever keep something I did I I
kicked an old man once is he okay oh he
beat the [ __ ] out
[Music]
I did it I can't get the ball have one
question do you have oxygen in a tank
guys I feel guilty I don't feel like I'm
helping the team as much as I should we
know that you know it's posible can I
please go and get a friend to help our
team is that okay I'll be right back
stay right here a little bit of football
[Applause]
you know these guys so you're on my team
yes right and we go against the other
Tina maybe we do a little better this
time what do you think you're okay with
it
perfect you're a hit let's do it what's
the plan what do you want me to do yes
[Applause]
Annie Conan O'Brien in Makeba terrific
come in taste rhizophora give a nice
annual primeiro geocell Yacht Segundo
[Applause]
[Applause]
what did you learn from me today when
playing football yeah what what skills
you saw some of my tricks what did you
just what did you learn I think your
first touch greatest touch my first
touch is great and also an agile like a
cat yeah Gothel call me el gato you
brought so much joy today here everyone
who plays thank you so much thank you I
have a year see Mexican Jersey for you
[Applause]
[Music]
yes I will wear this I will wear this
and I will play on your team do you want
that
perfect
you